if you've been reigning praise on the
brand new season of the umbrella academy
here are five other titles worth
checking out on this week's
binge guide the comic book series from
netflix based on the award-winning
graphic novels
is now certified fresh for a second
straight season and this family of
former child heroes who reunited to
protect the world
has been racking up a huge fan base in
the process
so if you've already binged season two
of the umbrella academy
try opening up one of these other shows
indoors starting with our certified
fresh pick
titans this dc universe show is based on
the teen titans comic books
and follows a team of young superheroes
that includes names like robin starfire
hawk and raven the series is from
co-creator greg berlanti who has also
brought us popular dc shows the flash
supergirl and star girl
and critics say the titans does justice
to its source material
while laying some fascinating framework
for where the show could go
you can binge the certified fresh first
season and very fresh
second season in about 18 hours and keep
an eye out for season three
possibly coming in the fall our under
the radar pick this week is the british
show misfits this one ran for five fresh
seasons
starting in 2009 and follows a group of
young offenders on community service
who develop superpowers after a freak
storm umbrella academy fans will love
the anti-hero nature
and odd super powers of these characters
as critics call this an
irreverent yet gritty drama that stands
out from the crowd
watching all five seasons will cost you
roughly 38 hours
and keep an eye out for actor robert
sheehan who stars as klaus
in the umbrella academy for our
throwback pick this week we are
thankfully headed back to the 90s for
the x-men animated series
this update of marvel's mutant
superheroes ran from 92 to 96
on fox and adopted a number of famous
story lines from the comics
with two of the five seasons at 100
fresh on the tomato meter
this show helped lay the groundwork for
the popular live-action film franchise
that began in 2000
because as the critics say it offers an
entertaining introduction for young fans
binging all 76 episodes will take you
just over 29 hours
and if anyone gives you any guff for
watching cartoons just show them your
wolverine claws
bub and satisfying your hunger this week
is our audience pick i zombie this cw
show that ran for five fresh
seasons and developed a rabid fan base
pun intended
is about a zombie who helps police solve
murders by experiencing victims memories
when she eats their brains yeah yeah
heard that right
bringing this show to life or would it
be death is a strong performance from
rose mciver and a show that critics say
brings an amusing variation on the
zombie trend
you can binge all five seasons in just
under 50 hours but if you get hungry
i would reach for the popcorn and leave
the brains alone
and finally our editor's pick this week
is the cw show
black lightning umbrella fans will love
the family vibe of this show about a
retired superhero
who is drawn back into action when his
daughter wants to get into the
crime-fighting game
critics say cress williams gives a
star-making performance on a show that
gives the superhero
genre a necessary jewel with real world
plots
and scary new villains with a fourth
season on the way you can bench the
first three fresh seasons in about 33
hours
and it's filled with great ideas for
family bonding activities
you know if you like taking out bad guys
okay hopefully you can add these to your
academy of shows you're currently
binging
be sure to let us know what you're
streaming right now in the comments
section below and
check back often for recommendations
based on the movies and shows
you already love be sure to subscribe
right here
and hit that notification bell that's
going to let you know when we have
another episode dropped
right here on the rotten tomatoes binge
[Music]
guide